flyover the new attraction coming to the  strip this fall is looking for employees  the immersive flight ride experience on  the strip  is filling 100 positions jobs including  ride operators  ticketing agents bartenders and a whole  lot more there's a link to apply you'll  find that on our website 8newsnow.com  mgm resorts looking to beef up their  security team the company holding an  in-person hiring event for security jobs  wednesday from 9 to 1. it's inside mgm's  career center  near paradise and sunset apply online  first at careers.mgmresorts.com  and for a full list of companies hiring  in the las vegas valley  head 8newsnow.com click on the job board  tab  we have put together a list with all  kinds of links for you to apply